batman arkham knight got itself a patch
this last weekend and while it's not the
one you need right now it's the one you
deserve actually no you probably deserve
another ten patches after this one one
of others and develop a rock steady have
released a patch which should fix a bug
related to disabling the game's rain
effects as well as a number of other
issues involving various crushers as for
the other bundle of problems Warner
Brothers have said they will continue to
release interim patches as they work on
improving Arkham Knights performance
issues the publisher explained quote the
work is significant and while we are
making good progress on improving
performance it will take some time to
ensure that we get the right fixes in
place you can check out the full list of
issues that warner brothers have said
they're working to resolve in our story
on games but currently they include a
support for higher frame rates fixes for
low resolution textures improvements to
performance framerate glitches distant
memory and v ram usage as well as
drivers for nvidia and AMD we'll be
keeping you updated on further back
touches as they're released so be sure
to stay tuned to gamespot